hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to agario i'm here to
show you how to get to number two on the
leaderboards first off you need ruthless
aggression to show no mercy to have a
complete lack of empathy for everyone
who's not you so what so long as I climb
the ladder to the top and probably not
die yeah so what so long as I climb the
ladder straight to the top and hopefully
don't die in the process all right cool
[ __ ] well that didn't work
I'm not going after you Garrett I'm just
trying to preserve my own integrity by
not dying or at least not dying legged
coward
cuz that's rule number four rule number
four don't die like a coward oh that's
what I'm talking about let's no plaids
oh that's doger I don't I don't like
doger John King and MLG pierogi are
having it out I don't want nothing to do
I had something to do did command it
come a big floppy dick I'm ruthless on
the pirate sees sonic gonna die I need
not even a dude at what I did it anyway
ruthless aggression ruthless hey look
it's John King looks like he suffered
after he came after me what a prick hole
mine mine my food Oh mine all my food
it's all my food don't even try do so
don't even try it
dank meme stir alright cool yeah you
better run okay me and me are gonna
stick together
he's me and me are cool lag is real is
not cool magaz real might get blowed up
I wouldn't mind doing this
there we go Hey look at that I have some
of those can I have that oh look at you
are you being all economical Oh Oh No
piccolo no no no no god dammit why why
why I could have loved you piccolo I
could have loved you and yet you did
this to me ha ha ha give me give me give
me some of these ha ha god I'm such an
idiot
oh my god ok alright whoa all right Oh a
little bit weird okay don't know what's
happening here
oh not looking so good now moon yeah you
better run what are you gonna do huh
Wally Wally oh [ __ ]
Wally Wally what are you doing stupid
he's too dumb get back here wait you
think you're a freaking GABA tegu I
almost had you I don't know what the
hell happened there well alright then
that happened wait boink thank you hey
you said heed me I'm on the common mine
mine and mine thank you thank you very
much well okay the lag is sincerely real
okay the lag is sincerely real oh boy
whoa holy crap that's scary that's
really scary whoa that's a whole lot of
scary my face cut easy
dammit god dammit [ __ ] you I hope you
die
just like this back off of my boy that's
my boy that's right that's my boy
thank you sir blah I don't know whether
I should help out sir blah but I think
more oh oh crap do not see big guy out
there oh thank goodness he went for some
well [ __ ] oh man this is nasty
no oh good juice how could you do that
to Sir block it was the real question
whoa Jesus
whoa Jesus okay well I took on fourth
place quickly [ __ ]
so as you can see through strategy and
blind pure luck I did something hi Joe
holy [ __ ] oh my god I took advantage of
something I don't know what though but I
took advantage of it let the dockside
flow through your little butt sighs
rougarou that's corner huh nice corner
yeah I know right
no that's strange
all right cool oh no no damn it
why were you going towards him fudge is
gonna be me you all me oh come on with
Doge Wally you want to just give up and
give me you qualit come on Wally come on
Wally
ah thank you it's not growing anywhere I
can't get to anyone I gotta make a move
I gotta make a big old
I gotta make a move somehow what the
[ __ ] is happening no no what is this
[ __ ] no I don't know what's
happening why why are you doing that I
don't know what he's doing but I don't
like it oh come on what is this [ __ ]
what Bell is this all about
that's right back off
oh no no no what the [ __ ]
Adams you big [ __ ] god dammit [ __ ]
oh hey life is so [ __ ] stupid stupid
piece of [ __ ] balls ass piece of Bologna
piece of Bologna
Oh Loney oh honey oh honey
Bologna Bologna Bologna Bologna thank
you god damn it [ __ ] me oh man
[ __ ] Oh piss and balls Adams with his
Bologna and [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god damn it
[ __ ] you
mm son of a [ __ ]
dammit [ __ ] there we go
[ __ ] you oh [ __ ] me
holy Sh still only number three I guess
I can take that not the worst thing in
the world
number four man everyone else in this
game is getting way too big I don't like
it I do much care for it I don't know
how I turned that around oh man
for anyone else that was privy to
everything that was going on there
hoo boy that was some loading bull loads
of I'm lagging like a son of a [ __ ] oh
my god why am i lagging now oh oh all
times to lag I can only hope that
everyone else is suffering the same fate
that I am with the lag whoo ok didn't
see him well big Papa now this is an
interesting predicament because Star
Wars on my ass but ok Star Wars and
China are right behind me so I'm gonna
morph very soon I can just get this
timing right I'm on Star Wars don't be
like that baby don't be like that
no come on what the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] son
of a god damn it [ __ ] you China yeah
they're working together to bricks why
why would you do that God working
together as a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
thing [ __ ] you Oh
number 2 god I don't even know how close
I was [ __ ]
it shirts Kate she at ski she at ski
chatsky why is mr. Faron I've been
following me forever okay yes please to
God thank you
finally holy hell le shadow lady can I
say hi to you
you're my favorite hey that's just rude
Oh eat him always like there for the
taking I thought he was playing a cruel
game ooh hello ask um my old friend okay
interesting strategy don't know why you
did that
okay cool well good good for you
congratulations oh come on
[ __ ] I thought that was gonna get me to
number one ha ha ha oh I'm just so close
ha ha ha I didn't mean to press that
button
I didn't mean to press that button my
thumb twitched cuz I was like ooh boy I
did good cuz what was gonna happen is I
popped him the other guy was gonna go
for the easy stuff I was gonna slip by
but no I'm a big goopy goo I'm just an
idiot so so anyway there's Marco pliers
patented Guide to Getting number two on
the leaderboard consistently always
number two in the next chapter I'll
teach you about that elusive number one
spot it's actually easy but I'm an idiot
so good luck without one thank you
everybody so much for watching that was
heartbreaking wasn't it so heartbreaking
oh well I love you guys anyway I know
that I probably messed up a lot in fact
I know I messed up a lot but either way
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video